i don't like eating vegetables when i
was young they had a fella in my
neighborhood named little allen
damn he was small brother he couldn't
even put a large grape in his mouth
and i'll say this every wayne somehow
gets called wild wayne which is
[ __ ] they need to definitely see how
much of these wanes
is wild oh i had a damn doe my god i had
a donut
a hamster is not a vettable animal
that's a to-go lunch for a wolf
some bad [ __ ] over there the uh
nashville mma put me into a damn figure
nine
last week i can't even answer the phone
in one of my one of my hands is all
stagnant because of whatever she did to
me damn hexed me
it's time to feel sexy quit feeling
homeless quit feeling like you just had
nine
pence of ice cream when my father still
lived with us we went to pizza hut
and it was a it was a damn four star
four and a quarter
four and a quarters ours it was a four
and a quarter star establishment when i
was young it could be a birthday party
and you blowing out a candle when you
seeing that flame go out and you catch
the eye of a real fine
match you know i got us
you want to look her in the eyes and say
look this little fella named mikey and
they called him roger but
his name was mikey but they called him
roger they sold uh pizza you know round
italian
people would pay for the salad bar just
fun of pudding
[Music]
twitter is a [ __ ] somebody out in
beverly hills got a
pet mosquito in a back brace [ __ ]
let the lord your frog has a lisp
that'll mean it needs a speech therapy
it needs a grave you know when they had
a guy used to live by me this boy named
chucky and he used to putting the
shopping carts away at dell champs and
he damn lied and he was doing drugs
praise god bam ptl baby can i cut this
thing into quarters because i knew out
the gate this was a bad
[ __ ] this little don i bet you can't do
it like me
oh but you can't do it like me but you
can't
do it like me you know when i was young
gummy bears was a damn
hell it was a [ __ ] program as a child
you thought maybe you might meet him one
day in the woods
but we would sit there and some kids
would piss themselves some kid didn't
even know how to work their bladder
their parents would bring them there and
they'd just piss out
what is that thing called not sims but
um it's like a battle
where you have crops and you know hey
donny get the wood you know
hey cheryl huh won't you farm
the family ended up having a damn fire
and somebody burned to death with all
the uh
best recipes i know it's been a while
i'm glad that you're here now and i'm
glad to be able to check in with you
do you have you been alive what have you
been what is going on
yeah yeah i've been alive okay and what
else man give me a little bit more than
that
give me have you been outdoors you've
been indoors
do vietnamese people get covered a lot
or no
i have no idea okay
any other words of wisdom
no
riley mao ladies and gentlemen i'm just
sitting
on your front porch wondering how could
i be so
far from my
[Music]
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been